so there's been a big discovery at the
lhc
uh they've discovered a pentaquark well
actually they've discovered two
pentaquarks so not one but two it's like
buses they've
two come along at once this is an object
of mata that's built from five quarks so
what we're familiar with before now are
things like protons and neutrons these
are examples of things called baryons
which are made up of three quarks so in
the case of the air the proton is made
up of two ups and a down quark and the
neutron is made of two downs and an up
they don't just have to be ups and downs
they can be charmed strange
top and bottom quarks and this gives the
sort of heavier cousins to the the
protons and the neutrons there's also
familiar things called mesons which are
made of two quarks where you have a
quark and an antiquark pair those are
sort of the familiar stuff but you can
and that's been theorized for over 50
years now that you could have
bigger objects
and what they've discovered at the lhc
is uh
finally they found an object which is
made up of five quarks at pentaquark
there have been evidence in the past for
tetra quarks as well and this is this is
all ongoing uh but yeah we now have a
five quark guy the one that they found
is built out of uh
two ups a down a charm and an antique
anti-charm so um it's a charmonium
pentaquark
and what does that then give you if
three quarks give us a baryon yeah what
do five quarks give us they give you a
pentaquark
that's what they give you that's what
it's called it's it's it's a completely
new type of matter
so i mean one thing we don't know and
obviously as they do more and more
experiments at the lhc and they'll try
to establish we don't really quite know
how these quarks are binding together
inside the pentaquark that's something
that they'll try to to learn you know by
by sort of doing more precise
experiments of the lhc i mean could it
be that it's like a sort of a baryon and
a meson sort of combining to form like a
kind of
giant quark molecule
or is it that they're actually really
tightly bound in a completely new state
of of five quarks this is relevant to
what was going on in the early universe
the states of matter that you might have
found in the early universe and also the
states of matter that you might find
inside neutron stars
so now that so when we think about you
know very very dense objects like like
neutron stars where the neutrons are all
packed together
it becomes theoretically possible you
start to wonder what other states of
matter can form inside that neutron star
and now that we're seeing pentaquarks
forming we now sort of have this real
possibility that you can have these
multiple quark states that are actually
forming inside stars and you can maybe
even think about quark stars and things
like that so they're very unstable
uh they would decay very quickly and
that's probably why it's been hard to
find and it's been criminally hard to
find them actually
but it's possible that some types of
like i said that you might find some
inside
deep inside neutron stars we talked when
we were at the lhc we talked about how
the lhc could be destroyed right and uh
we talked about strangelets uh
strangelets are sort of states of large
number of quarks
and in that case the know one of the
relief that we might have is that the
one that's being found at the lhc
is actually um
it's actually a charmonium pentaquark so
it's made of it's more charming whereas
the strangelets of course are sort of
multiple states of quarks that involve
strange strange quarks what's the point
of making these exotic weird things that
fall apart straight away it's a bit like
an architect making some crazy shaped
building
taking a really quick photo of it and
then it falls apart because it can't
stay up under gravity like you could go
and make any crazy thing but that's not
how the universe works well well
but i mean
they only fall apart in the conditions
in which you see around you they only
decay very quickly there might be other
conditions where they're more stable
and in fact
indeed in deep inside maybe a neutron
star the possibility is that these
things could could be
live for longer it's telling you
something about how
how the strong forces is interacting how
you know the details of how that's
working that's telling us something
fundamental about how things bind
together in nature how matter forms
matter you know if the only type of
matter that you see around you are
mesons and baryons and that sort of
tells you is that it but now we're
saying actually there's more exotic
objects that we know exist
but they don't exist you kind of just
stuck them together with blue tech for
half a nanosecond and thought quick
quick quick look take a picture and then
it just broke apart and you went ah well
well that's not really the case we don't
really know how how they're stuck
together yet that's still a question
that we're trying to answer you know how
how are they bound together i mean one
of the the sort of nice little stories
that goes along with this this whole
pentaquark tale is is how the mystery of
where they were i mean they were
postulated like 50 years ago by gelman
the great government where have they
been they've taken so long to find in
the mid 2000s there was this discovery
in inverted commas of something called
the theta plus pentaquark which is more
of a strange one
and uh you know there was there was it
was a five sigma result which is a very
sort of powerful result and there is
about you know is
one and a half times the mass of the
proton and this there is this uh
this pentaquark and it was hailed as a
great discovery
but then it turned out that
it wasn't a discovery at all you know
repeated experiments experiments that
were more sensitive went out and looked
for this pentaquark in the same place
and couldn't find it
and it's kind of it sort of died the
penta pop quark went away and uh it's
almost like people are now nervous
experimentalists are like nervous about
finding pentaquarks because of this this
story from the mid-2000s about that the
penta quark that never was
and
actually the the guys at lhcb that
discovered this one they weren't even
looking for the pentaquark it sort of
found them and in fact when they when
they found it they were a little bit
nervous about it because of this sort of
history that pentaquarks have
this is a nine sigma result though this
is now
as almost as certain as it could as it
can get
um
but of course it's still somebody else
needs to go and find it as well but uh
now that we're starting to find them
you might expect it to be a whole flurry
optimum a whole flurry of new particles
appearing you know you can even start
going to hexa quarks and all these sorts
of things you know really you're opening
up a whole new game of of quarks and
different types of matter that could
exist so basically what happened is as
usual in the lhc you smack two protons
together now what happened in this case
was those protons as they as they smack
together they form something called a
lambda b baryon
what is a lambda b baron it's basically
like a heavy neutron you take a neutron
you trade one of its uh
down quarks for a for a bottom quark
okay it makes it a bit heavy it's like
an exotic heavy neutron
and this basically this lambda b guy
then decays into
a proton
uh a k on and something called a j psi
which is like a amazon made up of charm
quarks what they noticed was that there
was a resonance in this in this decay
process there was a little bump
and that bump you would normally
associate with with a particle and it
was a particle which is mass was about
four times the mass of the four and a
half times the mass of the proton and
actually actually when they tried to fit
the data properly it didn't work with
just one
pentaquark they actually needed two
pentaquarks to fit the data which is
actually cast some dowels on the result
in some courses because it's like are
they interpreting the data correctly is
it one might have felt it's a little
strange that there were two rather than
one pentaquark there but uh they're
talking about nine sigma as well which
is
as good as it gets really we can only
dream of that in cosmology
and again
could you please close the mud